[Music]
my name is brian horton i'm the chair of
the margate town deal board
when the opportunity came up to be the
chair it's something i just couldn't
resist i think margate is at a
fantastically exciting time and i think
that both my skills and experience will
help uh bring that the opportunities
forward
but i think we've passed a tipping point
and it's you know an amazing time to be
part of this adventure which is the
margaret town deal board
[Music]
i think it's about unlocking the
economic potential for margate but also
really investing in our local people as
well so it's there to bring forward the
economic opportunity but also really
inspire and uh i think give ambition to
our local people to come along and you
know really benefit from the activity of
the town deal board
[Music]
i think what the tab what the investment
from government in the town deal will do
is help build confidence in others to
come and be part of the you know the
economic journey of the town so we're
really keen to shine a light on what's
really brilliant about margay
and show people the opportunity for them
to invest both businesses and
individuals to be part of that journey
with us in the future
i think it's that we're here
we're here to support them we're here to
support the town
and the reason i'm doing this is because
i believe in margate i you know was born
here grew up locally
and i think that
sometimes people in margay people in
fanny don't always see the opportunity
and this is a really important
opportunity and i just want to help
inspire people to be part of that and
benefit from it